projects so the story I want to say
here's a great pleasure to have you back
here what's interesting I think about
the work of the office and actually this
goes almost back into the incubation
period there are not so many houses not
so many that's unusual maybe a sign like
don't do houses just do really big
institutions there so they have a lot of
institutions and in fact the
institution's to get bigger and bigger
but interestingly they're kind of
architectural moves maybe get smaller
and smaller so some how is the scale of
the Commission the scale of the
opportunity gets bigger the actual
maneuvers and the precision gets more
these are kind of a quite simple
structures quite simple buildings but
with very complicated effects so maybe
and it's too easy to say it's I see
these architects very much in the in the
middle of the middle of the middle of
the mind of the architect which has
always been in mind that tries to
achieve a lot with a little bit like to
to achieve everything with almost
nothing and if the architect has not so
much big role in society nevertheless to
express the the big thoughts so
basically playing with input and output
like having actually quite small amount
of input and huge output quite small
elements but a big result very simple
geometry just a shifting of the color
and an explosion right so I think this
is in this sense they are it's gonna say
cliche but it's right in the cliche
understanding of what the modern
architect was trying to do right and so
in that sense I think it could be quite
simple to understand that the lecture
about to here is something like a kind
of update on the thinking of the
architect today working on the same
problem of all of all ways which is a
how to do a lot with a little
and I think that becomes a more
miraculous assignment when actually
society gives you a lot to do and right
now you have a very major role
particularly I think with in the recent
thinking of the mega planning concepts
and so on for for Madrid in any way it's
just a long way a long-winded way to say
you're super welcome here
thank you it's working
take it can be reinvested to mark
concerning the the Jan architect the we
always try to follow the advice not a
friend of us if to Amelia me and say try
to be always a kind of jump promising
architect because beyond that there is
nothing people with 50 years as we are
55 as I said we have this young
architect here now well we try to speak
we remember when when we were when we
were going when we were students of that
that's to say that is to say many many
years ago that we have a kind of
oppressive perplexity that we had when
when looking at the projects some
sometimes we wonder if the ideas just
come and fall from the heat and so we
thought it would be interesting
I do interesting for you and also maybe
for us it will need Christine idea try
to explore where buildings come from
where architecture comes from well never
part well just we can after a while we
can confirm what maybe you suspect that
it's buildings don't come from Paris
directly so this is to talk about the
process about the making of of a of a
project and we we try to speak about
tools and strategies that we use
throughout our work so the concerns that
that arise and how we went about them so
we
we will begin at the beginning it would
have been at the beginning of this
process of the Music Building so at a
certain moment at the Oromo competition
a lot of competition was held by the
director of the institution and it was
pretty surprising that the winner
proposed not to have a logo but to use
just these words music well according to
different events changing graphics that
Pavarotti and context so that has to say
that you can you can use this long just
shaving music on the back of your head
or writing with chocolate or knitting or
knitting in a pillow or ascribing on the
back of your hand and that very
unexpected proposal it was it was very
interesting because expresses very
precisely the character that the Museum
museum wanted to have this dynamic
transformation participation and
openness know so we would like to take
you on a ride throughout this process of
the music but this with this lady which
is not hiking well there is that
generally at least in Europe Architects
believe that there is a kind of the we
believe in the importance of the site
but the physical site but the first idea
we want to transmit is that there are
another landscapes which are maybe as
tangible or the physical side but we
have choose here these six landscapes
which is well personal intellectual
geometrical material historical artistic
or so
all natural it's clear that in every
project in this project there are more
landscape to work with and in every
project that you work there will be
another different different landscape
but this is a kind of world which is
around us and that's previous not I mean
we don't need to be architects to live
in this kind of world when a project
start some parts of this world will be
selected to form part of the project to
become part of the project and somehow
they will be magnetized they will be
attracted by the project in order to put
together all these parts that we are
concerned with and then start working
what is the aim of this lecture the aim
of this lecture is to say that to do
that some transformation of this
information has to be made this is a
kind of technique of doing projects
which well of course is not the truth we
are not giving you the truth not even we
are giving you our truth I mean we're
giving just an idea of how it will be
possible to organize or to work with the
things we have around in order to form a
project so at a certain moment some part
of this huge world will have around it
will form part of the project and a
process of transformation it's needed in
order to put together all these things
so we will go in counterclockwise around
all this let's see all these six
landscapes we call
there are more but well with ordinary it
will interesting just to go through this
six aspects what first one is the
personal one we don't like this world to
speak about something personalities but
we don't feel very comfortable but what
is but is what we mean by personal women
my personal the concerns would have as
human beings even if we're architectures
or we are not architects so this is to
say the way we lay in this world the way
we consider our relationship with nature
with art with culture or whatever and
that's very important because in our
opinion in general terms it will last
all the last time and this is related
with some kind of experience that I
don't know if you sometimes have
sometimes you see a building and you
point it to it and you can say well this
building was made by Alvar Aalto and
maybe you have never seen before this
building or Alto
no but to say you are able to recognize
that in this bring this plan in this
photograph there is a fight there is a
fight this case say between the idea of
putting the world in a kind of a struct
order and making possible at the same
time the dynamism of the life and when
you see these two things happening in a
plan you can point it and say well this
is
by Al Grantham so let's say that when
you start a project there is something a
kind of a probabilistic which is the way
you think about this world in our case
in our case we are always focusing in
this idea of equality and difference
which is maybe something that comes from
starting architecture when Franco died
and it was a dictatorship or whatever so
it's a social it's a political idea but
it's also an architectonic idea so our
question is would it be possible to make
visible somehow when you look up
architecture this idea of feeling like
belonging to a group recognizing
ourselves like a part of the group well
we are part of the same group at the
same time we can feel absolutely
different and this idea of equality
difference it comes through all the
projects we have done let's say during
this 25 years there are parts of the
prize that can be taught they say well
this is not important this is not
important not important but that is
important that's important and that can
be made in in a different place very
quickly for instance is speaking about
our first project this is the mish
Museum of Samora of course there were a
lot of different problems but let's go
to the herd they think the heart of the
thing is their family of skylines that
are absolutely identical but according
with the orientation according with the
distance with the with
another roof the floor according to the
space it will make different lights and
different space in the interior
no that's but it's the mission of the
Mora in the roof in the top level but
let's see the Aldi torreón of caste on
there are a lot of things related with
with acoustics a lot of products we are
not going here to speak about this
problem but again it's a family of
windows they've recognized themselves as
belonging to a group that while there is
an Orthodox order you can see seven
eight nine ten eleven divided and there
is a proportion between this but the
height and the depth of the windows and
in the interior of that there is a hole
an actual window which is related with
the interior necessities but we are
always focusing this idea of equality
and difference or in the Museum of
Castilian we try to enter with this idea
in the interior of the building working
with sections now we start saying we
will start thing is a well we'll work
with with with the roof will work with
the way the facet what about working
inside inside with this idea so there
are like four different levels or
different plans and then a double high
space it's supposed like a cascade that
make every floor different when you go
through it so in one hand you have the
same surface you start the same to
exaggerate the same screws in every plan
but when going through it become
different so in some how this idea of
equality and difference can be expressed
by a family of skylines by a family of
windows by a family of double Heights
all the projects we have done could be
explained through through this idea so
you have here this this is like a kind
of map of what we have done in these 25
years well there is the geometrical ones
at the beginning we were speaking about
but you can work with this kind of
geometries very simple geometries that
we will speak you can work with circles
for instance a familiar circles they
will recognize and same themselves like
belonging to the family of circle that
there will be different on on science or
petals petals of flowers but whatever so
the interesting thing it's it's this is
incredible you take just one idea
whatever it is and it can be expressed
in a many different ways you can keep
what know the whole life maybe next year
if we have the opportunity to be back
here we will explain another thing but
work right now but right now it seems
incredible how infinite is whatever idea
we just focus on so the way every plan
can be explained to that so we transform
this idea of equality and difference
through this plan in which there are
just square and rhombus rhombus square
rhombus squares where rhombus is where
vamos etcetera and the light which is
the cheapest material of doing
architecture it will make different
every part so even in this wild rigidity
even this value 3 DVD the space will
become
different but at the same time they will
recognize themselves as belonging to a
kind of funny which is something as we
were seen before it's important but just
some images of the interior of them
sections when it was finished - but to
spread this idea that depending how the
light is coming well from skylights from
corners from windows it will make
different what is exactly what is
exactly it's incredible
for us when we are right to the lobby of
the project that the client asked us
about having eight different directions
or doors but it was the cafeteria the
offices library
the museum itself entrance so at that
point it's more like 11 meters the size
of these names so that point we have for
two squares and two wrong so it began 22
metres 22 metres for us it was very nice
to think that in the lobby of this
museum it was the size of the first Muse
the total size of the first mission we
have done so you can first the head that
you spend four years to do to decide
this Muse you know and Mary for this
whisper for weeks but that was
interesting so so the problem is that
you need a beam which is torque that is
not it's not straight beam if you if you
want to continue with the discipline of
having the same geometry so that gives a
very huge
beam so this bin is its it will be seen
over this flat Museum because the client
asked to have just one floor so we
decide well it's it mister is there if
he's there something up to this to this
building well there will be the same
done the other things that are going up
in the building which are a skylight
also decide but let's put the skylight
here and we will see and the incredible
thing the incredible thing is that when
we make that the pin is crossing this
way as you can see so one skylight will
receive northern light a blue in soft
light another one will receive south
light which is yellow strong and that's
an important and incredible lesson for
us in architecture we were dealing
during 25 years about equality and
difference and just going ahead just
going ahead with a technical problem it
appears in our opinion the nicest view
of this quality and equality and
difference because one is later on in
the in the afternoon in the evening they
will interchange their roles and there
will be a kind of soft light in one part
I'm very bright and solid and orange
right in the other so this is this is a
kind of work very heavy doing
architecture is something very heavy but
there are some instance of pleasure this
is when you discover something that is
beyond your creativity beyond your
credit
and then it appears the unexpected thing
and then you become not the architect
but the aspect actor of this thing and
this is a only pleasure but we think is
the only pleasure of architecture well
the rest you have to work a lot that
let's go to the second to the second
landscape that we use this war intellect
well but we don't like this world we
don't like this world but we are
architects we're not writers with normal
we don't we don't like this world this
is also a kind of physical space which
is the concerns architect would have and
we can see that as a something very but
it's very complicated but the same time
is for example is very example because
architecture is in pure art that is to
say that we have ideas but we have to
deal with these ideas with reality that
gravity with budgets with clients with
regulations so at a certain moment
sooner or later it will be it will
appear contradictions and the
intellectual pleasure of architectural
is to deal with these contradictions
this is the interesting part of the of
the of the architecture so in a way but
this traveling made by the one person of
the of the one architect or of the
office while he was trying to establish
the the module of the glasses of the of
the perimeter but what we were speaking
about is what is the role of the
architect on deciding the form of the
which no maybe it seems something very
simple for for you or no or maybe
something very complicated but but we
were we were concerned about this custom
I mean when when when you you can start
thinking that well maybe it's better to
define the form of a building through
diagrams of people crossing through but
you can establish the form of the
building through the speed of the cars
that are close to in this high high road
or highway or when you can work with
computers and makes columns there is a
problem there the problem is well said
generally not one very very deep the
promise what is the way of dealing with
this problem of defining form it's
something that belongs directly to the
inspiration or the arbitrary key of the
architect or should we take into
consideration exterior aspects that will
help us to explain to us and to the
others what is the right form of the
necessary form of the things so we start
working with this with this idea with
with emsac with this open systems so we
are right and at that moment we change
totally the way of thinking architecture
before that there was like kind of
buildings that has to explain it very
quickly like a center or hierarchy it's
you can recognize that there is an
origin but just imagine just imagine a
cathedral which is very Breton you can
recognize where is the center where is
the Isles were the most important parts
or not but we start trying to imagine it
will be possible to work with a kind of
doing architecture in which every part
knows what it's close to it but it does
it don't doesn't care about what is the
relationship with other forms use that
that would be an interesting idea of
answering about the formal the final
formal of of the prize not that those
are like different stage of scale angles
etc for the museum but a certain moment
we realize that the final shape or form
of the building if it was not important
at all because during the process of the
project and during the process of
construction even there was the client
say but I will need I would need some
more space for exhibition what doesn't
matter
we can either we can address for I don't
need more space for storage is too big
what don't worry we will take one we
will take hard one one wrong no so
through this process which was not the
aim of the Vienna investigation we
realize that a system which is not
hierarchical so which is just base it in
part to part relations makes indifferent
somehow the actual or the final form of
the building that it should say that it
doesn't matter maybe if this is the
final form but it will be different for
someone of you or us that arrives
they're busy decide it will remember the
space has been the same and the idea you
will not change it will not change even
if there is formal formal formatting
sober this is a model which is trying to
explain that which you can you can add
or transform part of it without taking
care about what the formal the final
form of the
building yes let's go to the next the
next landscape which is about
construction did the client ask us just
three things you know maybe here you
have like a like a book like this but
this plane the program is just 10
minutes conversation which is I don't
know if it's good or bad but well I
didn't want just one floor I want you to
enter in eight parts when entering in
the lobby that was up here this special
geometry and I want the building to be
done very quickly so we thought that we
have to think about a structural system
and construction system so this idea of
equality and difference it was very
useful for that because we built that
with 65 beams that are absolutely equal
oh it's the same piece is benefits in in
a rhombus if it is a square it means
exactly the same so we decide to go to
this process of restriction of materials
and transformation so we decide well the
walls will be made in white concrete the
beams will be made of mud concrete's the
the floor it will made in black concrete
but material it will be the same and
construction finishes finishing a space
it will be the same thing once that you
build that the building it's almost
finished but here I think we have here
we do not a kind of small history of the
big construction of the building
what it was incredible know that the
people that have start doing a part they
continue doing this response and doesn't
matter there is a teachings or not they
know exactly how to do it so we will
have write this this space which was
actually very important so we were
displacing to this historical so what is
the relationship between the building
and the history of the city of the
context we were very concerned from the
nineteenth about avoiding formal
relationships what but the things we
have around what was very important in
Europe and especially important in Spain
so there was a kind of fight of saying
well don't think about it you have this
kind of window you have to do this kind
of window just think about which is the
concept of this window and try to make
this the concept of this window at a
place no that was very interesting so at
that point and at this point maybe I
have to explain that it's very difficult
to explain a process which is not linear
in a linear way so I'm sorry about that
but a PowerPoint is something that after
one image comes another image and well
who tried to make this in in counter
clockwise and make a circle or whatever
but it's clear that these kind of things
doesn't happen one after the other it's
more a process in which a different
moments and with different importance
appears concerns and you have to deal
with and certainly like in English in
the same form well the idea is that this
part of the city that you can see in
but hearing that in the upper part it's
a new part of the city's order just
blocks of dwellings and park spaces so
we thought that the it will be necessary
to have like kind of Piazza or plaza
square so that's the explanation of this
part of the form so they form the
overall form of the building it was not
important except by the idea of having
like two arms embracing or receiving the
people that live in this in this part of
the city so the very at the very
beginning the project the client asked
us what I would like the most modern
building and I would like to have like a
giant video wall covering all the space
what was it but let's let's do it let's
wait when we arrived to the client with
the budget you say well you know sir
the budget of the building is 10 and the
budget of the video wall is 10 what do
you want us to do well say what forget
about the video world well write about
the video wall and there were some
colors here well we start with the good
start going ahead with the with the
projects and then well it happened
something interesting we start dealing
with these colors I don't know you but
we don't have any artistic for
background so sometimes you start with
the color what do you think
to green what do you think too
fashionable too old-fashioned I got one
month two months three months to
exaggerate it now to say what man so we
decided to go to the prime minister as
it wasn't a prime minister we think we
think that this building will be
wonderful just in white
let's try to convince the client no and
then at that moment he said something
marvelous he said do you promise me
colors too
and you have to give me colors my god a
nice client no at least he knows what
what he wants which is strange so my
million me back 350 kilometers to to
Madrid in car in silence but a certain
moment we make a visit with a friend and
then we work we went to the cathedral
and these friends say Oh what nice
colors and I look to a mean you mean we
got it anything so we took the this part
of the stained glass which is the most
unseen parties that is called the hunter
of the of the Leon and we go through a
process of digitalization I think maybe
here it can be expressed very well this
idea of transformation so you can
establish a relationship with the city
with the cathedral which was the unsent
public space of the city you can take
something and transform in in by means
of your time
maybe this digitalization it would be
impossible to be done 15 years ago
what at least in Spain here but it will
be it would be impossible to know and
it's very interesting because well we
write each part and so people of the
city knows that and some of them says oh
I can't see the hunter which is
absolutely impossible - they are like 40
kilometres the distance of it but it
doesn't matter
it's a the point is the same
they know that the hunter is there and
let's go let's go hit with this process
of that's what we suggest the tool to
the claim that he didn't want the
incredible thing the incredible thing
and this lecture is part of something
that you have thought and something that
you discover after it was the process of
putting distance or taking distance on a
distancing distancing is an English verb
distancing from things so these colors
doesn't belong to us
that was a problem when we were trying
to do the chorus no there were our
colors with our signature ugly or or not
ugly but there was a kind of wind person
thought that that is clear that we as a
Spanish architect we never we will never
put the Spanish flag in this building
now so it's a it's a matter of putting
distance art and it and being surprised
by the things you are doing that belong
somehow to the others and not to you
well they deal with the planning it was
the same
Leon Leon that if you translate it
directly means lion but the name it
doesn't come from lion it come from a
military camp by Romans which was called
lessee of septima so they may be just to
say that it was like an Roman one of the
dresser Roman origin of the city so we
took Roman pavement of the of the museum
and we establish our process of scaling
it in order to transform this geometry
as the plan
of the building so we did this part and
then we enlarge it when once again let's
say we steal we steal some part of the
history of the city and we transform it
and appears to be part of the project
that was very interesting because some
some time later when won't be so when we
said this proposal will realize that
actually the dem circuit was like french
fries on together
mad mad but we that was later will be
nice to have seen at the very beginning
now and that the museum should be like
french fried french fries so but what's
the interesting thing that once again
you are taking the instance of it and
you are disappearing so nobody well in
our opinion will recognize when visiting
the museum that this is a proposal made
with this amount of squares and rhombus
that are absolutely rigidus while the
materials but become invisible
somehow and that may be the most the
most interesting and the most difficult
part of architecture let's say the first
one is to have an idea
the second one is to make it invisible
in order to free up space for the others
the less space you are consuming there
will be more space for the others for
piston people but it was some some
photographs interesting in the debut
what what you discover when when doing
that that you are used maybe or you
thought the the visibility of the
building it will be through names but
when when is built or constructed you
realize that your eyes
doesn't our audience to you they will
look as they want well as a matter of
fact that was a lesson of history for
instance let's say that the Alhambra the
la mezquita de Cordova which is made
with this idea
that's a column because there is an art
there is not it will be never you will
never take the photograph in this
direction but and I didn't die on a
format but we do realize that later is
not that later about some photo result
is this entrance of the delight through
colors in the areas that that's possible
not the exhibiting areas for instance
cafeteria bar shop whatever so let's go
to another landscape idea is that but I
have to be very very careful because I
remember I was I was giving a lecture in
I think it was in Stockholm no and I was
trying to say that there are like
different levels in architecture no not
but instead of saying that there are
several layers as evolve in architecture
there are several liars no layers I
think I want to say late legislators so
there is that there are different words
different parts of work and we are
always trying to magnetized and to put
them giving an idea of what you think
about this part of the of the world with
the same form but it's clear that it's
very important that it was very
important they live the way they museum
want to work want you to work and it was
kind of transformation we made during
these 10 years saying first museum we
made in 90s the beginning of 90s it was
like an like logical Museum and it was
made with in a historical and
chronological process and it was basic
in most important parts like when we
when we went to the museum of caste June
we start thinking that world importance
it was not just beside the building and
the works of art it was important also
the people that was visiting this art
know so we try to make this kind of
stomach by the stomach just for people
to see one two to each other know and we
try to go ahead with this with this idea
of having the ending music as something
in which you are thinking contemporary
and pieces of art and person as forming
part of the same time we like very much
this photograph which is the the day of
the opening I think the King is like
this but but the interesting thing is
that the day the absence of will of
these combinations of quarrels is the
absence of we love that combination of
colors another person up there
that was that was interesting for us not
to consider that the building could be
what is this some workers smart I see
that there is a lot of people that speak
Spanish here no although or there are
just important words this evening but me
wasn't our heart well what was
interesting is the the changement of the
philosophy of this I'm very unpopulated
area of Spain is the most unpopulated
area of all Europe of all Europe so
there is this what you can see the
school
in this combination well they they saw
everything
it's know everything but wanted us is
this difference that is deciding at this
work from Thomas Hirschhorn in which
George's crossing through working
through this work this work of art so
it's not anymore this idea of having
distance the ambition of the museum is
to present the art as something that can
be touched and can be can be can be able
to establish a relationship with it that
was a little in shock when this thing
turns you inside of the journal there
was this very wonderful nice
in every moment
sorry
well this is the connection that that
was very very nice person exhibition
make the speaker and things
no erotica in a way but this is premised
the exhibition of Al Green improv set
and was specially made for this for the
music and was six houses that represent
six different events of his personal of
his personal life
it's a little more like that how to say
no offstage you know they will appear
different things in different ways well
concerts and well let's go to them to
the last one nature it was it was before
doing this music project we made this
small new suit that was closed for 1260
to another 72 the maintenance and the
auditorium so we spent we spent like
seven years but every Wednesday we cross
the stage to the side the BC by car and
coming back and it was really very
impressive
what but we used to see in this
unpopulated unpopulated area and maybe
if we have to tell you the truth that
starts at that moment now we remember
crossing every Wednesday in winter in
summer spring in Iran this boy
absolutely Boyd area and in the interior
that there was this fields I think it's
a long blow it
flow with fields and after two or three
years Monday we were believe me and
currents in well it's incredible so it's
the reason very strict order the
relation between things the perimeter
becomes absolutely indifferent because
the order is
further to that to the interior no and
we asked ourselves it would be possible
to make a building like this it would be
possible to make a building in which the
or the internal order is so strong that
it becomes indifferent the order that's
in the other part in the in the
perimeter or in the form in the actual
form of the building so at a certain
moment it becomes together like several
things becomes together the idea of
having a very geometrical order that
becomes independent the idea of what is
the in the role of the architect in the
definition of architecture the idea of
having unknown hierarchical building the
idea of having a connection with the
history with Roman pavement no well that
was the same with the it's like flock of
birds flock of birds and something
somewhere I'm going to take one this is
like a way kind of know everyone we will
see in this plot a different thing but
this is not the important part of the
important part is if you take out some
parts of the perks or you put more birds
of you put different birds the idea that
would be the same everybody will say
what this is a flock of birds
it's a flock of birds and Emilia me was
asked in but wouldn't be possible to
make a building like this well it's a
nice question that I live do to you to
whom to do this kind of building which
is very difficult and with we doing were
not not able to do
and also this this very interesting
history for us when we presented the
first project to the Prime Minister and
but someone missed the entrance there
will be the collection there will be
exhibition there is not one thought and
he said what I love it I love it
but but what is it but this is some
using here's the entrance the wrong
boosting the the origin of the city what
what sorry we don't we don't understand
what would you are asking that oh he's
just because the world that was left
behind in Spain
well you know there are buildings like
like like fish or like mountains and
what what should I say
what should I say to a journalist my god
we don't know Emilia meet 350 kilometers
in silence back back back to back to
Mali
well at a certain moment we discover
that this part of the Spain which is
called Caspian alone
it is just the physical space of a river
which is called Duero that would wine
I've recommended the wine and then it's
just defined by that the region so well
video will have to go we'll have to work
then well Prime Minister well look this
museum is like the river well you know
you can see here the
you see the movement of the of the
walther that means that it's coming up
and down you know there are seven seven
regions and we have seven spaces and
well at the end while the heart is like
the water so which the same are always
different now you say well great well
let's go with a journalist know and he
is incredible because seven years later
every time that the music appears in the
in the newspapers is the music which is
like the river who arrow so that's an
important reflection because we don't
believe you can build architecture with
metaphors because you become like is
posted for from the very beginning no if
we say well I want you to make up I want
to make a building just like the river
but you cannot move you have no no
freedom but we have to reflect about
that fact that we have to explain things
and sometimes for explaining things we
need metaphors so what what's happening
that that we need metaphor for
explaining buildings but the only
securities well we cannot use them for
producing architecture because we do
just will be you will have the capacity
of moving in quantity in quantity terms
but not in quality terms you will not
escape so six or seven years later every
time but the music which is the well we
are almost finishing with this release
what perhaps they've a nice bottom rap
about this order that has but you can
see very well the river here or here
even better just to to before finishing
just trying to recover what would have
say which is not very difficult is
pretty normal I mean we have a water
we are architects but before that we are
persons as it as the others
most of us so in this world in every
project some part of it it will form
part of the project will be selected
somehow but through this process of
transformations by the means when we try
to arrive to a sample as possible form
in which let's say it can be visible for
whom host who's that want to see it
different levels an opinion or a will in
relationship to the today to the city to
the history of the city today concerns
about exhibit even if there are
different welcome that will be different
in any case with our personal concerns
and the work is trying to magnetize and
put together all this thing this is a
it's a hard work but it's a nice work
it's an it's an it's a nice work well
and just just for finishing we will go
to the beginning again because something
very very interesting happen well I know
that here in the United States you are
very precise with with the timing of the
works but this doesn't happen in Spain
at all so we were asking to make a very
quick building and we did it
but the client was not faithful for it
so he the first programmation
it was like three months later no say
what they will they will take three more
months I will prepare for exhibition so
we are finished on time and that was a
problem for the director because that
there the building was finished and
nothing nothing to do with the building
now it was impossible so he has an
incredible idea very cheap idea he said
well let's do an exhibition with
scholars the division is is made by you
or something like that no see so he
asked he all the children's of the city
and were like like eighteen thousand to
go to the museum and to put the money to
do what run away on the paper because he
promised to the parents of the children
that he will keep the drawings in the
museum no so they're very proud the
Father Almighty my my daughter has a
flower in the museum you know that's
true that there are we have seen that a
bit their kid so but it was very
interesting so it was a very cheap
exhibition so everybody went to the
building it was Christmas time also that
was interesting word in there were space
for doing that there were time for doing
that and the interesting thing is that
people understand what was the character
of the building in which they expect
people to somehow participate or be
engaged in this in this kind of
institution that's very neither that was
mean by Eduardo el Moussa now with the
door incredible or that is very nice
very nice so this idea of trying to
having the same photograph or the people
for the building it was very important
for us well I'm just finished this is
the final one last summer there was a
friend of us to send this photograph to
say I don't know if it's good or if it
is bad because before the construction
of the Mossad were they after the
wedding people goes to the Cathedral to
make a photograph and now they have
decided and it's much more better to go
to the min-suk I think it's also because
the the Sun in waste but it's not
exactly but the interesting thing is
that this back of the building it
appears to be like a landscape or
something it's something that well but
it belong it's nothing it's nothing let
me better say so it's like I mean then
having a tree which is green or maybe
it's orange or maybe it's red in autumn
you make the photograph and the
protecting the protagonist it will be
these people and it's something that
looks very nice and we're we're very
happy
so everybody move to the music domain is
wedding photograph so the director which
is very clever thought that the next
exhibition it can be to have all the
photographs of the people and we are
sure that he will he will sell all the
catalog thank you very much
sheesh on making of the yes yes I think
that definitely we were very well direct
firms very lucky because the the the
director shared with us this idea he has
been working during this for years
almost four years and they used to make
like five exhibition every six months is
very interesting the process because
there are five different exhibitions
that maybe sometimes one are well Jong
local artist four-inch recognized in a
group of and then the day of the opening
they moved all together in this this
different spaces it was very clever and
he's fighting very hard very hard
actually but a small city in nowhere
land and has become a space or but from
my feet and then they will come for the
openings of order to see and you will go
there and there will be people always
all they know it's incredible we're very
lucky I mean the success is not it's not
just I mean architectonic mister sexist
when when when they when the Prime
Minister the client and the director
feel that that the the idea is the same
and it's possible to share it that was
very very important i I'm wondering how
the mechanical systems and environmental
controls and energy efficiency plays
into how you approach a building well
and had time to explain this these kinds
of things in in concept terms do you
remember the river of the hoof
yes well every space it has a separate
control so in mechanical terms let's say
in geometrical terms the ducts security
air condition etc is located in separate
areas and it comes through these walls
of water but it was also a concern that
you have seen they were like high
buildings so the idea of offering a kind
of roof and interesting roof it was it
wasn't important no so they are divided
and then in terms of efficiency what
it's more important we think that in
Spain for the bad and for the good we
are
traitor shadows we're late behind we
were behind and that means that that it
has been absolutely important to keep
the importance of passive systems I mean
it's not is not a power country in
technology terms but it's actually a
power country using materials
in passive terms so you have the the
concrete the the well concrete and then
you have the insulation you have an air
chamber and up the glass so for the Sun
which is the the biggest problem so
there is this kind of ventilation that
comes that comes and try to make a lot
of change of
to necessities but but it will it's
focused just in that very well 20 life
right materials and something that it's
very important for us which is
durability in economic terms sometimes
to be sure that that you can build a
building the rule the resist 20 or 25
years is something for us something
environment
hi you have said that they don't like
using metaphors in your project but we
all know they place fork on table for
example three mountains or the flowers
or the can for example for Olympic Games
Murray a quad using that kind of
metaphors no we're using that kind of
metaphors to explain to the prime
minister's great no yes yes no this is
curious because for instance that the
first of Cantabria well I don't know if
you know something about it but it was
like a step forward on this one here
we'll have square of rhombus so we
decide it will be possible it will
possible to work with just with one
piece so the mission of Cantabria is no
there are not two different piece but is
the same piece and you can put it like
this but when we interchange this
freedom in sectional terms so I don't I
don't know how to split that well you
make a building and appears a concern
and the concern of the Mossad it was
well okay you can work with that and
there are a lot of advantage that we can
recognize but there is a kind of
limitation this is an extruded building
oh yeah if I had to make a criticism of
the musak no it's you cannot make
movements in sectional terms so we said
well next step we have to assure that we
have moving sectional terms and for
doing that you have to reduce the
complexity of the plan
so the idea it was to work with just one
figure and make him different lettuce
the section which is something that
doesn't exist that Moussa but you say no
you cannot say well police in the
section of the museum doesn't exist
because it just won't work so we will
have to deposit the expression
of the building into the plan that was
the power this another landscape I know
so the the idea is that if you can have
the same plan and then build in
different shapes that actually in her
just three different sayings but they
mean it's an economic thing I mean that
was possible it will reduce but it
appears to be all different but they are
known are no different they're like the
same but that interchange and that that
was there let's say the the problem but
when we shall the the building these
people say these are like the mountains
so we made that problem with the
mountains but when sometimes you have to
kind no he'd hide to to it is condemned
to hide but it was not it was not it was
more about the quality and different
so the idea it was a political idea
difference is just possible if there is
a common order the person from that but
later on it seems month times but but
but for or else it was not important it
was not important at all in the stadium
in the stadium it was just the
structural model it what they can so we
decided to make a study that was open
but it was very difficult to solve
instructional terms so there was someone
that they did they can say well this is
like the time but the photograph appears
but this as I was saying before there
are no things linear now they appear in
that's in in different moments let me
show that you can explain very quickly
the structural model of a building with
a kind of code but it's clear that
there is not a Connor then appear a
building on they they don't they don't
fall from heaven
you describe this lecture under three
landscapes is that the way that you
describe this project or is that the way
that you're thinking in architecture and
is there one of these six landscapes or
whatever that is your starting point in
in your design no we're just trying to
establish the idea that the work of
doing architecture it has to do with a
lot of different things and that each
one of them are important not more
important or less important and say that
that I'd say that in my opinion in our
opinion it's impossible it's impossible
to establish a model of twin
architecture without establishing what
is our relationship with nature and
culture maybe maybe maybe guilt dude you
don't know the words but you have a
feeling of it and in our opinion it's
impossible to make it with indefinitely
of that and also there is a discussion
about what architecture is and what are
the concerns of the architecture are and
it's impossible to make a building
unknown having a reflection on that and
they're evil as the history well is it
nature whatever but the starting point
it's it's very difficult I always say
that that in in in Leon in music the
starting point it was this plowed fields
as an obsession but it's more imagine
that you are like a garden a garden you
know and then you have some ideas and
then you do plant then what about doing
that what about Linda what about you and
then
but then then we started spring no you
do water them
there you see but let me resist the
water the garden it's not traditional
it's not resist in the water let's say
water has talked about system for
anything huh
there is a lot of sang here look this is
this is becoming dry no because because
it has nothing to do or instant with the
concerns of all the people in
relationship with the function now they
prefer that decade the flower no and
then Paul let some spring summer well
and at the end when there is one that
resists all listen to it do it angel
just take it and that's it nope well
we're talking about substances I mean it
check and it's nice to see that some of
them those goals ahead are able to to
receive al conveys different concerns
before interpolation logistical systems
like to miss them security problems
something that it's very different in
Spain that in a United States that
architects are personally responsible
for all the things have big difference I
mean that's why sometimes it looks like
being a little bit conservative because
if you make a proprietor $600,000,000
there will be just one signature and
it's choice so the structural engineer
it will disappear I mean nothing happens
you go to the Yale and that's it
so that's why we are very engaged
sometimes maybe too engaged
thinking about this relationship between
the structure
space air-conditioning finishes or water
which is is also interesting because in
the other hand did you if you are
absolutely responsible you have
absolutely all the power but it's uh
it's something heavy
sometimes it's something
I think Teresa was saying in the
beginning it's some new idea about
efficiency it's another way of
understanding thank you